NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RACE NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. BAUER
QUE HAN. BENNETT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BURKE. CALDERON CARRILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY OCTOBER
SMITH. STONE HANG VALLADARES
THE ABUJA VOEPEL WALDRON WARD
WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. YEAH. I AM VERY MUCH.
I DON'T REMEMBER ANYONE THERE.
MEMBERS ACQUIRES PRESENT WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. OH GOD. REVEALED THE
BLESSINGS OF DIVERSITY. AND THE
MANY SHAPES AND FORMS. THAT IT
HAS BECOME MANIFEST IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND IN OUR WORLD. MAY
WE ALWAYS SEE OUR DIFFERENCES.
AS A SOURCE OF STRENGTH. MAY IT
ALWAYS BE USED TO UNITE. AND
NOT TO DIVIDE. MAY THIS BE
GOD'S WILL I MEAN. TAKE YOUR
MIND YES SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVIES AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE OF THE STATE. PLEASE
PLACE YOUR HAND UPON YOUR HEART
VETERANS MAY SALUTE READY
BEGIN. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE. EIGHT ZERO SAN ASIAN. YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LITTLE. YEAH
WELL. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. MHM ARE SACRAMENTO WAS
APRIL FOURTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THIS ONLY MINUTES SEVEN AND
HONORABLE JACQUI IRWIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FORTY FOUR JUST
PRESIDING SHE CLERK SUE PARKER
AT THE DESK READING CLERK DAVID
ABLEMAN READING FOLLOWING ARE
PLACED ON THE MORNING RECALL
SEVENTY FOUR AGARKAR IRAN
BECAUSE IRAN IS MOVES AND
MISTER FLOOR A SECOND STEP THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE- TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US. AND WE'RE
AT PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MS RAYOS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
GRAYSON HOLDEN TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE AB TWO FORTY TWO
HOLDEN AND ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX
EIGHTY THREE THIRTY FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH. THE CLERK WILL
THE. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN LOW FROM
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILL TO SECOND
READING THE BILL IS NO LONGER
FISCAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AND
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER. AB THIRTY
ONE O'DONNELL FROM THE RECENT
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING.
CALGARY SOME OF THE THIRTY
THREE THE MOMENT A LIVE IN
SEVENTY ONE FIVE FIFTY WITH THE
MINISTER TINA SIX ELEVEN SIX
NOW THE MEN'S FORTY SEVEN SEVEN
OF THE VENTOLIN FORTY FOUR
MINUTES TO FORTY MINUTES
FOURTEEN SIXTY WITH THEM
INSTALLED THIRTY SIX MINUTES
FIFTY THIRTY SIX OF THE MEN'S
FORTY NINETY FOUR MINUTES
FIFTEEN THIRTY TO ADVANCE TO A
TWENTY THREE THE MOMENT SUNDAY
WITH AMENDMENTS SEVEN THIRTY
TWO MM IT'S A FIFTY OVER THE
MINUTES TEN THIRTY THREE OF THE
MINISTRY SOME UNANIMOUS FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO AT THE MOMENT.
394-023-6230 727-967-9750
1-764-838-4059 OF 310-402-1270
EIGHT FOURTEEN AT. THREE
FOURTEEN NINETY FIFTEEN FIFTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THIRTY NINE TO
EIGHTY THREE TO NINETEEN THREE
NINETY EIGHT FOUR FORTY FOUR
FOUR FORTY SEVEN FOUR SIXTY TO
FORTY FOUR FOUR NINETY TWO FOUR
NINETY FOUR FIVE TWENTY SIX
FIVE THIRTY NINE. FIVE FORTY
SIX FIVE NINETY NINE SIX OH
THREE SIX TWENTY THREE SIX
SIXTY THREE SIX SEVENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN SEVEN FORTY NINE A
TWENTY FOUR EIGHT SIXTY
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE ELEVEN
TWELVE AND FORTY EIGHT TOLD
221-320-1409. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTEEN FORTY ONE FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOURTEEN THIRTY TO THE
MEMBERS TWENTY WITH THEM INSIDE
FIFTY WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHTY
NINE AT NINE THIRTY NINE
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN SEVEN
HUNDRED MM INSTALL THE ONE OF
THEM'S EIGHT EIGHTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS FIVE OR SIX OF THE
MOMENT. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WITH
HIM TO LIVE IN A SIX OF THEM'S
NINETY WITHIN MINUTES FIVE
SIXTY WITH EVENTS AND A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS. ALL BILLS. WILL BE.
READ AND AMENDMENTS. DEEMED.
MEMBERS REMOVED- ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS. EIGHTY
FIVE. FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
PASSED RETAIN PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY SEVEN. THROUGH
NINETY FIVE. PASS AND RETAIN.
EVERY SYSTEM FILE ITEM NINETY
SIX AB THREE SEVENTY ONE BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THIS IS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY ONE
OF THE MEMBERS BY SOME MEMBERS
JONES. MISTER JONES SAWYER ON
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU I RISE
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS AB THREE SEVEN ONE
WHICH ADDRESSES MEMBER CONCERNS
AN OPEN MARKET ACCESS FOR THE
TYPE OF INSURANCE WOULD
NORMALLY PROVIDE THIS
INSURANCE. AFTER CONVERSATION
WITH MULTIPLE INSURERS WE CAN
AND ARE WILLING TO PROVIDE THEY
ARE WILLING TO PROVIDE THIS
INSURANCE CLARIFYING THESE
AMENDMENTS ALLOW TO PROVIDE
LIABILITY COVERAGE FOR
PEDESTRIANS AND ACCIDENT
VICTIMS. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS
THESE ARE AMENDMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYES. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT. YOU MEMBERS ARE DUBBED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT. M. BACK ON
FILE FILE ITEMS NINETY SEVEN.
THROUGH NINETY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE
BRIEFLY BACK TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MS REYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE O'DONNELL
FROM THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MS REYES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. NOW MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE HUNDRED.
MS VALLADARES ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT. FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED
AB TWO SIX SEVEN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLE TO SIXTY SEVEN BY SOME
INVALID THERE'S ANOTHER SNACK
WILLING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. MS VALIDATORS. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH IS A NECESSARY MEASURE
THAT WILL STREAMLINE WILDFIRE
FUEL AND REDUCTION PROJECTS. IN
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS YESTERDAY I
HAD PREPARED MY REMARKS FOR
THIS BILL AND IN THOSE REMARKS
I WAS GOING TO HIGHLIGHT HOW
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT CONDITIONS
MAKE IT RIGHT FOR FUTURE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. I
WANTED TO DRIVE HOME THE POINT
THAT WE CANNOT CONTINUE
TIPTOEING AROUND THE OBVIOUS
CALIFORNIA IS IN A DROUGHT. AND
OUR OPEN SPACES AND FORCES ARE
WOEFULLY IN NEED OF TREATMENT
AND CARE. I WAS PREPARED TO
STAND HERE AND CONVINCE YOU
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
CHANGES TODAY SO THAT TOMORROW
WE CAN ALL BREATHE EASY. THEN
LATE YESTERDAY I STARTED
RECEIVING DISTRESS CALLS. FOR
MY CONSTITUENTS TEXT MESSAGES
FROM FRIENDS AND EVEN MY FAMILY
MEMBERS ALERTING ME TO A
WILDFIRE IN MY DISTRICT. NOT
BUT A FEW MILES FROM MY HOME.
AND MY DISTRICT OFFICE THAT
FIRE HAS GROWN TO ONE OF THE
LARGEST WILDFIRES WE RECORDED
THIS YEAR. I GOT REGULAR
UPDATES AT THE BURN OF THE BURN
AREA. AS IT GREW FROM FIFTY
ACRES TO TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ACRES. TWO HOURS OF THIS
MORNING SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ACRES. THIS FIRE HAS PROMPTED
THE EVACUATION OF AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY BETTER BACK HOME THIS
MORNING AS OUR FIREFIGHTERS HIT
THAT FIGHT HARD LAST NIGHT.
IT'S POLLUTED OUR AIR WITH
NOXIOUS SMOKE AND ASH. AND
WE'RE STILL IN APRIL. I WISH I
COULD STAND HERE TODAY AND TELL
YOU THAT THIS FIRE IS AN ODDITY.
BUT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US ON
THIS FLOOR KNOWS. THAT IS SADLY
A PART OF THE NEW NORMAL THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE BEING FORCED
TO LIVE WITH. WE CAN NO LONGER
SHY AWAY FROM THE BOLD ACTION
NECESSARY. TO TACKLE WILDFIRES
WE MUST COMMIT TO PROGRAMS AND
FUNDING THAT ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE THERE IS NO PROGRAM
TO GREAT. AND NO PROGRAM TO
SMALL. WE MUST MITIGATE THESE
WILDFIRES AT EVERY LEVEL
POSSIBLE. AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIXTY SEVEN IS A BILL THAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE. MEMBERS TO
HELP SAFEGUARD OUR COMMUNITIES
AND TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
WILDFIRES. THAT POSE TO OUR
HOMES TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND TO
LIVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THEY CAME IS VALID AS MR
FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE
A PROUD TO AN AUDIT OF AB TWO
SIXTY SEVEN. IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
ARE A CONSTANT RISK IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE DEVASTATING
AND WE HAVE ALL SEEN THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF EACH
WILDFIRE SEASON. THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE REAL. WITH A
WILDFIRE THAT STARTED YESTERDAY
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALL%
WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH IN OUR
OWN DISTRICTS IT MORE ACTION IS
NOT TAKEN. IN THE AKE OF THE
LOOMING DROUGHT IT HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE IMPORTANT TO
STREAMLINE AND ACCELERATE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EFFORTS TO
REDUCE FORCED FEEL LESSEN THE
SEVERITY OF FIRE SEASONS. AND
HELP BUILD LONG TERM WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. AB TWO SIX TWO SIX
SEVEN DOES JUST THAT THIS BILL
STRIKES A PRACTICAL BALANCE.
BETWEEN PROACTIVE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BUILT ON A B. TWO SIX
SEVEN. THANK YOU MUCH FALL
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM IS ABOUT
THEIR HUMAN CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND SUPPORT ON AB TWO
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU. WITH
THAT THE CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY THREE
KNOWS TO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO JUMP TO SENATE THIRD
READING. SENATE THIRD READING
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE TWENTY
SIX. S. B. NOW. TWO MISTER
TAYLOR GOING TO PAUSE FOR ONE
SECOND.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEMS ONE A ONE.
THREE ONE OH SIX PASS AND
RETAIN. MISTER O'DONNELL. HE'S
GOING BACK AGAIN ONE CHANGES.
MEMBERS CALLING ANOTHER AUDIBLE.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A MISTER
CHANG'S BUDGET ITEM THIS IS
SENATE THIRD READING. SENATE
THIRD READING S. B. NINETY TWO.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX SB
NINETY TWO CORKERY. SENATE BILL
NINETY TWO BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET OFFICE
CURFEW AND ACCORDING TO
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND MAKING A
PROVISION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECTIVELY BUILD RELATED TO
THE BUDGET. MISTER K. YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB NINETY TWO WELL ESTABLISHED
THE REALIGNMENT OF THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE TO COUNTIES
THAT WERE INCLUDED THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET OCT. IT'S
TECHNICAL CONFORMING CHANGES
AND ESTABLISHES A CLOSURE DATE.
OF JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IMPACTING APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY JUVENILES. ANNUALLY SB
NINETY TWO PROVIDES GUIDANCE
FOR THIS TALISMAN A USE OF
SECURE YOU TREATMENT FACILITIES
FOR CERTAIN YOU. WOULD HAVE
BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR A COMMITMENT
TO DJJ. JUDICIAL COUNCIL BE
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP AND ADAPT A
MATRIX OFFENSE OF. BASED
CLASSIFICATIONS WHICH INCLUDE
PROVISIONS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF REAL. OF A REHABILITATION
PLAN AND REGULAR PROGRESS
REVIEW HEARINGS OF YOUTH. ON
THE SECURE TRACK. THE TOPICS OF
THESE PROVISIONS WERE
ORIGINALLY INCLUDED IN LAST
YEAR'S BILL. SB EIGHT TO THREE.
BUT IN RECOGNITION OF NEEDING
ADDITIONAL INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. WE COMMITTED. TO
COMPLETE THESE PROVISIONS IN
THE SPRING. DURING A SIX MONTH
PERIOD WE RECEIVED INPUT FROM
JUDGES. PROBATION COUNTIES
YOUTH ADVOCATES WHICH
ULTIMATELY CULMINATED AT S. B.
NINETY TWO WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER TEAM FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. NINETY TWO
NOT ONLY DOES THIS BILL
INSTITUTE SUBSTANTIAL POLICY
CHANGES THAT ARE INAPPROPRIATE
FOR A TRAILER BILL. BUT IT DOES
A HUGE DISSERVICE TO YOUTH
OFFENDERS IT WOULD BE PUSHED
TOWARDS COUNTY PROGRAMS THAT
RECEIVE MINIMAL SUPPORT FROM
THE STATE. AND EVEN WORSE IT
STILL LEAVES COUNTIES DEPRIVED
OF CONSISTENT FUNDING AS WE
SLAMMED MORE MORE RQUIREMENTS
THEIR WAY. THIS BILL ADVOCATES
FOR BOTH A COMPLETE
REORGANIZATION OF OUR JUVENILE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THE
SENTENCING REDUCTIONS. A
TRAILER BILL IS NO PLACE TO
PUSH THROUGH AN ENTIRE AGENCY
REORGANIZATION LET ALONE
ADVANCE SUBSTANTIAL POLICY
CHANGES WE ARE DEALING WITH AN
INCREDIBLY FRAGILE AND VOLATILE
POPULATION. THESE YOUNG
OFFENDERS HAVE BEEN CHARGED
ABOUT POTENTIAL WITH THE
CHARGED WITH THE RAPE MURDER.
ARSON ROBBERY KIDNAPPING
ASSAULT TORTURE OR OTHER
SERIOUS CRIMES YOUTH OFFENDERS
IN IN THE PROGRAM NEED
INTENSIVE PROGRAMS RANGING FROM
COUNSELING TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT TO OPPORTUNITIES IN
EDUCATION. BUT BY DIVIDING THE
RESPONSIBILITY AMONG COUNTIES
TO HOUSE THESE OFFENDERS
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES WILL BE
INCONSISTENT INEFFICIENT AND
ISOLATED INSTEAD OF OUTRIGHT
CLOSING DJJ WE OWE IT TO THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO
CRAFT A COLLABORATION. BETWEEN
THE STATE AND COUNTIES. TO FILL
THE NECESSARY AND CRITICAL ROLE.
OF A TREATMENT CAN TO. CONTINUE
ON FOR THIS FIVE OF OFFENDERS.
BUT SB NINETY TWO SHIPS TOO
MUCH RESPONSIBILITY ON DRUG
COUNTIES WOULD NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH SUPPORT TO JUSTIFY A
VOTE TODAY. BY AND LARGE THIS
IS A CLEAR ABUSE OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS I HAVE SAID BEFORE THAT
WE REVEAL OUR MOST DEEPLY HELD
PRIORITIES IN CRAFTING THE
STATE'S BUDGET. USING A TRAILER
BILL AS AN END AROUND OUR
POLICY COMMITTEES PARTITE IS
ONLY CONVENIENCE OVER
CONSTITUENTS I URGE A NO VOTE
ON SB NINETY TWO. THANK YOU MR
FONG SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. MISTER
KING A CLOSE YOU WISH WITH THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IS THAT A
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY TWO. NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN REGULAR FILE
ORDER ON ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN.
AJ ARE NUMBER TWO MISTER
O'DONNELL CLERK WILL READ. SOME
JOINT RESOLUTION NUMBER TWO BY
SIMON ON ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO
COASTAL MARINE WATERS MISTER
O'DONNELL. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. MEMBERS. BAKER
MEMBERS I STAND RESENT AJ ARE
TOO WHICH CALLS UPON CONGRESS
AND THE FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY TO TAKE ALL
MEASURES NECESSARY TO PREVENT
THE DDG DUMPING SITE NEAR
CATALINA ISLAND FROM CAUSING
FURTHER HARM TO OUR OCEANS AND
CALIFORNIANS CITIZENS. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN CITIZENS FROM
USE SCIENTISTS FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA PUBLISHED THEIR
FINDINGS FROM A MULTI YEAR
EXAMINATION OF A SITE ON THE
OCEAN FLOOR JUST NORTH OF
CATALINA ISLAND. THEY
DISCOVERED SOMETHING THAT HAD
ONLY BEEN RUMORED BEFORE A
TOXIC WASTE DUMPING SITE WHERE
BARRELS FILLED WITH DDT LACED
SLUDGE WERE BARGED OUT OVER THE
OPEN OCEAN AND TOSSED INTO THE
WATER. IN SOME INSTANCES THE
BERYL'S APPEARED TO HAVE BEEN
FIRST STRUCK WITH AN AXE BY
THOSE ORIGINALLY DISPOSING OF
THEM TO ENSURE THEY WOULD SINK
TO THE OCEAN FLOOR. A PRACTICE
THAT NEARLY GUARANTEED THEIR
CONTENTS WOULD SEEP OUT INTO
THE SURROUNDING WATERS. A
RECENT SURVEY OF THE SITE
DISCOVERED OVER TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND BARRELS OF WASTE WITH
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS MORE
BURIED BENEATH SAND. ON THE
OCEAN FLOOR. IN ORDER TO BE
PROPERTY STEWARDS OF OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES WE MUST
WRESTLE WITH THE MISTAKES OF
THE PAST AND ADDRESS THE DAMAGE
BEFORE IT GETS WORSE. DDT IS
BAD STUFF. IT HARMS WILDLIFE
AND HUMAN LIFE. AG ARE TWO
CALLS UPON OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO TAKE ALL
NECESSARY STEPS TO STOP THE
HARM THE SITE CONTINUES TO FLEX
INFLICT UPON CALIFORNIA'S
RESIDENTS AND WILDLIFE AND OF
COURSE COAST. THANK YOU MR
O'DONNELL MISTER MURATSUCHI ON
THE RESOLUTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO JOIN. MISTER
O'DONNELL AND CALLING OUT. THIS
HORRIBLE HORRIBLE CRIME THIS-
INCIDENT IS IN THE NEW YORK
TIMES IF WE COULD SEE EITHER IN
TODAY OR YESTERDAY'S NEW YORK
TIMES THIS IS PERHAPS THE
GREATEST ENVIRONMENTAL CRIME IN
THE HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SCALE OF THE
NUMBER OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BARRELS OF DDT THEY'RE
JUST JUMPED OFF THE BEAUTIFUL
COAST OF IN MY DISTRICT OFF OF
THE PALACE VERDES PENINSULA IT
OUT FOR FOLKS THAT EVER BEEN TO
PALACE BIRDIES IF YOU TAKE A-
DRIVE ALONG GOOD AT PCH DRIVE
YOU SEE SOME OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL CULTS OF DEALS VIEWS
IN THE ENTIRE STATE. BUT
UNDERLYING ALL THAT WATER THAT
BEAUTIFUL COAST ARE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DDT BARRELS AND
THERE'S A WHOLE LAYER OF DDT
JUST SITTING AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE OCEAN THAT'S GETTING INTO
OUR FOOD SUPPLY THAT'S
THREATENING NOT JUST THE
WILDLIFE THAT THREATENING OUR
CHILDREN OUR FAMILIES SO WE
NEED TO CALL OUT THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES THE U. S. EPA TO
PROSECUTE THIS AS- FOR WHAT IT
IS A ENVIRONMENTAL CRIME. THANK
YOU MISS REYES WHO G. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING%
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION
MISTER O'DONNELL YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH YES SIR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE WHO OFTEN SERVES IN
THE VERY WATERS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW AND ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AND MR DON WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE AJ OUR-
YES. MEMBERS FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON AJ ARE TO
CARPOOL THE ROLL NUMBERS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS CO AUTHORS. THIS IS CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ADDING ON THE RESOLUTION. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY
CO AUTHORS AT IT THIS IS AN H.
A R. WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE- IS
OUT OF THE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL I SEVENTY NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. FILE
ITEMS ONE OH EIGHT THROUGH ONE
TEN PASS AND RETAIN. FILE ITEM
ONE ELEVEN IS A. B. EIGHT OH
FOUR BY MISS DOLLY THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY IT'LL FOR
US MY DARLING AND ACTORS INTO
HUNTING. THIS DALY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB EIGHT OH FOUR
AS A SIMPLE BILL THAT
ESSENTIALLY CHANGES I MADE TO A
SHALL IN CURRENT LAW TO REQUIRE
RATHER THAN AUTHORIZE THE
DEPART THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE TO DECLARE TO FREE
HUNTING DAYS ONE IN THE FALL
AND ONE IN THE SPRING. THIS
WILL REDUCE FINANCIAL BARRIERS
AND INCREASE ACCESS TO OUTDOOR
SPORTS AND RECREATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
DAVIS TO BIGELOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT OH FOUR WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE TO ESTABLISH TO
FREE HUNTING DAYS A YEAR.
CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN A STEADY
DECLINE IN SALES OF HUNTING
LICENCES. WHICH IS CONCERNING
SENSE CONSERVATION EFFORTS ARE
FUNDED THROUGH THE SALES.
HUNTERS ARE NECESSARY ALSO FOR
KEEPING ANIMAL POPULATIONS AT A
HEALTHY LEVEL. BY ENCOURAGING
EXPERIENCED HUNTERS TO MENTOR
NEW ONES WE CAN FURTHER OUR
NATIONAL GOAL OF RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION. WHILE INCREASING
FUNDING TOWARDS OUR
CONSERVATION EFFORTS I THINK
IT'S WELL WORTH NOTING THAT.
THE HUNTERS TODAY AS THEY HAVE
DIMINISHED FROM ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND ANNUALLY TO
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE WITH
THE DOLLARS THAT THEY ARE
CHARGED FOR THEIR LICENSE AND
FOR THE TAGS THAT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE TO GO IN FRONT AND ANIMAL.
THIS IS IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE LOST OR
CONSERVATION EFFORTS THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE UP IN SOME WAY.
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IT'S IT
TEACH PEOPLE ARE RESPONSIBLE
AND RESPECTFUL WAY. TO USE
THEIR FIREARM WHILE TAKING AN
ANIMAL. THANK YOU MEMBERS I
ENCOURAGE A STRONG AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BELA. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ADEMAS DEL YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. WE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT. CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP AS
FIFTY SIX NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR REQUESTING A VOTE
CHANGE ON SB NINETY TWO FROM I
TURNED OUT. WELL CHANGES AMEREN
MAIENSCHEIN SENATE BILL NINETY
TWO I TO KNOW. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
AND ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE
ARE MOVING BACK WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
SIX. MR MAIENSCHEIN YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZE THE COMMISSION SHALL
SB NINETY TWO I TEND NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGES SOMEWHERE
MAIENSCHEIN SENATE BILL NINETY
TWO I TO NOT VOTING. MEMBERS
ARE MOVING BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SIX. AB TWO SIXTY
THREE BY DR ARAMBULA THE CLERK
WILL READ. A SINGLE TO SIXTY
TWO BY SOME AROUND ANOTHER'S
AND ACTING TO PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES INCLUDING THERE JUST
AFTER TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
DR ARAMBULA. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AB TWO
SIXTY THREE THE HEALTH
OVERSIGHT AND LEADERSHIP AND
ATTENTION ACT TAKES STEPS TO
HELP TO CLARIFY THAT ALL
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES.
IN THE STATE MUST ABIDE BY
STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDERS. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
HOLDING PRIVATE OPERATORS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE ACTIONS AND
POLICIES THAT IMPACT PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE BILL ALSO EMPOWERS
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AND
PROVIDES THEM WITH CLEAR
FRAMEWORK TO SECURE OUR STATE.
WE NEED THEIR LEADERSHIP NOW
MORE THAN EVER AND THIS BILL
MAKES THEIR JOB EASIER. AT
PRESENT CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
SEVEN PRIVATELY OPERATED CIVIL
DETENTION FACILITIES THAT HAVE
A CAPACITY TO HOLD UP TO
SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
AT ANY GIVEN TIME. THESE
FACILITIES POSE A UNIQUE AND
CRITICAL CHALLENGE WITH RESPECT
TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND OVER THE LAST YEAR
HAVE BEEN THE SITE OF MASSIVE
OUTBREAKS. WHILE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN IN PRIVATE DETENTION
ARE DIRE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
DETAINED. IT SHOULD BE OF GRAVE
CONCERN GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THIS POTENTIAL
OUTBREAK HOUSE FOR CALIFORNIA
AS A WHOLE. OUTBREAKS IN THESE
FACILITIES CAN QUICKLY
OVERWHELM LOCAL HOSPITALS AND
DRAIN MEDICAL RESOURCES
THREATENING COMMUNITY HEALTH
AND PUBLIC SAFETY. CIVIL
DETENTION FACILITIES THAT HOUSE
IMMIGRANTS HAVE REQUIREMENTS IN
THEIR FEDERAL CONTRACTS WITH
RESPECT TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THIS INCLUDES LANGUAGE
REQUIRING EACH FACILITY TO
COMPLY WITH CURRENT AND FUTURE
PLANS IMPLEMENTED BY FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES
ADDRESSING SPECIFIC PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES INCLUDING
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS WOULD
INCLUDE PLANS FOR TESTING OR
VACCINATIONS FOR COVERT
NINETEEN TO HELP US MITIGATE
THE SPREAD INSIDE THESE
FACILITIES. BY CLARIFYING THAT
ALL PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES IN THE STATE MUST
ABIDE BY STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS AB TWO SIXTY
THREE INSURERS STATEWIDE
COORDINATION THAT IS NEEDED TO
SECURE OUR STATE DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY SIXTY ONE
COUNTY AND CITY LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS AND DEPARTMENTS BY
POSITION GROUPS BY IMMIGRANT
IMMIGRATION RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS BY THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AMONG
MANY OTHERS AND AS A BIPARTISAN
AUTHORED BILL. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR. SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLICK LEVEL THEY'RE ALL.
MEMBERS WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IT IS OUT OF A. CLERK
WILL. THOSE ARE ALL TIED ABOUT
I. SIXTY ONE DOES YOUR ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES.
YEAH MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
REGULAR FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTEEN. ONE FIFTEEN
AB THREE EIGHTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. BURKE
AGREED WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
THREE TWO WITH AMENDMENTS BY
SOMEWHERE IN THIS AREA. MISTER
NAZARIAN ON THE IMMINENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN- TO
ENSURE LABOR REPRESENTATION OF
THE- WORKGROUP WILL ALWAYS-
REMAIN AND- THIS BILL WILL
EXTEND- THE SENSE THAT THE FOR
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEASURES
AREA WITHOUT OBJECTION I MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
S. HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT TO
BACK. ON FILE. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN
MOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN. HR NINETEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETEEN MY SUMMER
MULLIN RELATIVE TO TARDIVE
DYSKINESIA AWARENESS WEEK.
MISTER MIND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
PRESENTING HR NINETEEN. MANY
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS CHRONIC
MENTAL ILLNESS REQUIRE
TREATMENT WITH MEDICATIONS THAT
WORK AS DOPAMINE RECEPTOR
BLOCKING AGENTS INCLUDING ANTI
PSYCHOTICS. WHILE ONGOING
TREATMENT WITH THESE
MEDICATIONS CAN BE VERY HELPFUL
EVEN LIFESAVING UNFORTUNATELY
FOR SOME IT CAN LEAD TO TARDIVE
DYSKINESIA. TV IT WILL READ
THIS ORDER THAT IS
CHARACTERIZED BY RANDOM
INVOLUNTARY AND UNCONTROLLED
MOVEMENTS OF DIFFERENT MUSCLES
IN THE FACE TRUNK AND
EXTREMITIES TV CAN DEVELOP
MONTHS YEARS OR DECADES AFTER A
PERSON'S STARTS TAKING
MEDICATION AND EVEN AFTER THEY
HAVE DISCONTINUED USE OF THOSE
MEDICATIONS. NOT EVERYONE WHO
TAKES THESE KINDS OF
MEDICATIONS DEVELOPED TV BUT IF
IT DEVELOPS IT IS OFTEN
PERMANENT. THIRTY SUGGESTS THAT
THE OVERALL RISK OF DEVELOPING
TV FOLLOWING PROLONGED EXPOSURE
TO THESE DRUGS IS BETWEEN TEN
AND THIRTY PERCENT. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS SUFFER
FROM TD YEARS OF RESEARCH HAVE
RESULTED IN SCIENTIFIC
BREAKTHROUGHS IN THE LAST YEAR
WITH TWO NEW TREATMENTS FOR TD
APPROVED BY THE- US FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION. TEDIOUS
OFTEN UNRECOGNIZED IN PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM THE ILLNESS ARE
COMMONLY MIS DIAGNOSED. SINCE
YOU TAKE THESE KINDS OF
MEDICATION SHOULD BE REGULARLY
EVALUATED BY THEIR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO ENSURE THAT ANY
SIGNS OF TDO RECOGNIZE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION AN ASSET
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN. FOR CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU MISTER MILAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS A CALL AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
LOOKING FOR ME. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IN THERE TO VOTE. THIS IS
YOUR CAL AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRTY VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT
THERE ARE SIXTY EIGHT CO
AUTHORS ON HR NINETEEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL IN
FAVOR SAY I'D- ALL OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE EIGHTEEN
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY WILL TURN SIXTY FIVE
IN THE MOMENTS BY SOME
INFORMATION. MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AMENDMENTS AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE NAME OF THE
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION FINE
AUTHORIZED BY THE BILL THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THERE IS MAIENSCHEIN
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THEIR ALL. I WAS
AMENDMENTS. PARTY MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR AMENDMENTS THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
I. SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS AT THE PRINTER BACK ON
FILE. FILE ITEMS. ONE NINETEEN.
THROUGH. ONE TWENTY FOUR PASS
AND RETAIN THE SENATE THERE
READING PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FIVE.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP. SOME
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. BY MR
LOW CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SOME OF THE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE OF THE MOMENT BY
SOME MEMBER LOW. MISTER LOVE
THE MOMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENTS. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO CONSENT CALENDAR
THERE IS A RESOLUTION. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR WHICH THE
AUTHOR HAS REQUESTED CO AUTHORS.
WE'RE GOING OVER THE ROLE NOW
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THAT ITEM.
KERKORIAN SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
PAN RELATIVE TO BLEEDING
DISORDERS AWARENESS MONTH. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE THIS
IS FOR COOPER'S ON THAT
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLARK WELL CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED. ON THAT
RESOLUTION. ALL THESE. THIS ANY
MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
AND HEARING DOWN THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR SOME OF THE FOUR
THIRTY BY SUMMER GRAYSON
ACCORDING TO DEBT COLLECTION.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALLMEMBERS VOTERS OUT
ABOUT THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS THE
CONSENT. CALENDAR. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSER ALL I SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. THE CLERK WILL MAKE
WILL READ ANY REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY WILL SIXTY THREE I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
ASSEMBLED TO NINETY SIX I.
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO A SINGLE
TO NINETY EIGHT I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
OH SIX I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTEEN I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FORTY ONE I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO ASSEMBLE FOR SIXTY SIX I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY FIVE
I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
ASSEMBLY WILL SIX FORTY FOUR I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO A SINGLE
SIX SEVENTY THREE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN
FORTY TWO I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO A SINGLE NINE FIFTY SEVEN.
I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO A
SINGLE TUNNEL FOR WITH THEIR
DANCING. I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THE URGENCY I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS HERE ON THE BILL A SINGLE
TEN FIFTY EIGHT. I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO ASSEMBLY ELEVEN SEVENTY I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
WILL TWELVE NINETY I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETY ONE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY WILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY I SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO ASSEMBLY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WITH URGENCY. I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVEN HERE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE BILL SINGLE
FIFTEEN EIGHTY TWO I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO SINGLE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO SEVEN THREE FIFTY ONE I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
TWO. I SEVEN EIGHT ZERO ZERO
AND. ASSEMBLY RULE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY SEVEN. I
SEVENTY NOW. ZERO MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. YEAH WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED A GERMAN TO MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR.
LET'S READ THE
REMAINING ITEM ON CONSENT.
SENATE CAN CRUISE
COUNTERREVOLUTION THIRTEEN I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO MEMBERS
WE ARE AT A GERMAN TO MEMORY
THE QUORUM CALLS BEEN LIFTED.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. OR TAKE YOUR
SEATS. AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET AT THIS
TIME. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN. IN THE MEMORY OF
RETIRED MAJOR GENERAL DAN HELIX
OF CONCORD. AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE HIS SON AND DAUGHTER.
WHO ARE ABLE TO JOIN US TODAY
UP IN THE GALLERY. FOR THIS
ADJOURNMENT. GENERAL HELIX WAS
AN AMERICAN HERO AND A KOREAN
WAR VETERAN WHO COMPLETED A
FORTY ONE YEAR CAREER SERVING
BOTH ON ACTIVE DUTY. AND WITH
THE ARMY RESERVE. HE IS A
MEMBER OF THE U. S. ARMY'S
INFANTRY HALL OF FAME AND SOME
OF HIS DECORATIONS AND AWARDS
INCLUDE. THE COMBAT
INFANTRYMEN'S BRIDGE A BADGE
ARMY DISTINGUISHED SERVICE
MEDAL SILVER STAR LEGION OF
MERIT BRONZE STAR WITH V.
DEVICE FOR VALOR. PURPLE HEART
WITH OAK LEAF CLUSTER
MERITORIOUS SERVICE MEDAL ARMY
COMMENDATION MEDAL AND NINETEEN
OTHER AWARDS. HIS SERVICE TO
HIS COUNTRY AND COMMUNITY DID
NOT END THERE DURING THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES
GENERAL HELIX SERVED AS MAYOR
AND COUNCIL MEMBER OF CONCORD
AND AS A DIRECTOR OF BARK. HE
LATER RETURNED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND TEN AND
SERVE THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
IT WAS DURING THIS TIME THAT I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING
ALONGSIDE DAM ON THE CITY
COUNCIL. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
THEN TO BOTH LEARN HOW HE
SHAPED OUR COMMUNITY. AN ASPECT
OF LIFE IN THE COMMUNITIES OF
CONCORD IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THAT THE MAJOR GENERAL DID NOT
PERSONALLY WORK ON TO IMPROVE.
HE BROUGHT MUSIC ENJOYED TO THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH HIS PART IN
CREATING THE CONCORD PAVILION.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
CLOSURE OF THE CONCORD NAVAL
WEAPONS STATION AND IT'S A
VENTRAL AVAILABILITY TO THE
CITY OF CONCORD AND DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION. DAN WORKED
WITH HIS COLLEAGUES ON THE CITY
COUNCIL TO TRULY SAVE OUR CITY
AND REBUILD THE RESERVES
ACCOUNT TO AN ASTOUNDING THIRTY
PERCENT. THIS IS JUST A BRIEF
SNAPSHOT SNAPSHOT OF THE MAJOR
GENERAL SERVICES IN THE TIME I
WAS PRIVILEGED TO KNOW HIM I
WITNESSED HIS LOVE FOR HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. HIS
COMMITMENT TO HIS FELLOW
VETERANS AND SERVICE MEMBERS
AND HIS PASSION FOR IMPROVING
OUR COMMUNITY. DAN WAS MY CLOSE
FRIEND MY MENTOR AND MY PER
PARTNER I WILL ALWAYS MISS HIM
SORELY. AND I CAN STILL HEAR
HIS VOICE AND WORDS OF WISDOM
SUCH AS PLANNED STRATEGICALLY
FIGHT TACTICALLY TELL WHAT TO
DO NOT HOW TO DO IT. AND STAY
ABOVE THE BATTLE AND BEHIND THE
SCENES ALL ALONG WITH DON'T
WALK TOO FAST YOU'LL MAKE
PEOPLE NERVOUS. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE OF SIXTY SEVEN
YEARS MARY LOU THEIR TWO
CHILDREN DR DANIEL FELIX AND
MARY LOU L. IT FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO GREAT
GRANDDAUGHTERS. I WISH HIS
FAMILY AND LOVED ONES COMFORT
DURING THIS PAINFUL TIME AND
ASKED THAT MY COLLEAGUES JOIN
ME IN A JOINING AND RETIRED
MAJOR GENERAL DAN HELIX'S.
MEMORY WITH MUCH LOVE. THANK
YOU MISTER GRAYSON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS OFF FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DAVID
H. LEWIS A BELOVED TEACHER AND
MENTOR. DAVID LEARN EARLY THAT
HIS LIFE'S MISSION WAS TO HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL. AND STARTED HIS
CAREER AS THE CHRISTIAN
EDUCATION DIRECTOR FOR CAMP
GILMORE ONE OF THE SUMMER CAMPS
AT THE SALVATION ARMY AND
CALABASAS. HIS FAITH GUIDED
MANY OF HIS DECISIONS AND GAVE
HIM THE CONVICTION TO CONTINUE
TAKING ON MANY ROLES TO HELP
OTHERS. HE'S BEEN OVER THIRTY
YEARS IN THE AZUSA SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS A GUIDANCE
COUNSELOR TEACHER AND DIRECTOR
OF THE THEATER ARTS PROGRAM.
HIS LEGACY WITH THE THEATRE
ARTS PROGRAM IS SEEN IN
STUDENTS WHO GREW THROUGH THEIR
CONFIDENCE AND FAITH IN
THEMSELVES IN THE SAFE UP
LIFTING SPACE DAVID CREATED.
FOR SOME THERE WAS A SECOND
HOME. HIS FAMILY STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY WILL MISS HIM DEARLY.
DAVE SUFFERED A STROKE IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY BUT WAS
ABLE TO SPEND A FEW MORE MONTHS
SURROUNDED BY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS BEFORE HE PASSED AWAY
ON MARCH TWENTY SEVENTH. HIS
LEGACY OF SERVICE IN LOVE. WILL
LIVE ON IN THE NEWLY NAMED
DAVID H. LEWIS THEATER OF THE
PERFORMING ARTS AT A ZOO SO
HIGH SCHOOL. WE GIVE OUR
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY AND
WE THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
MS RUBIO IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER YOU TWO ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE SHERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND THANK YOU MR
HOLDEN FOR THOSE KIND WORDS I
TO RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
MR DAVID H. LEWIS. WHO LEAVES
BEHIND A LEGACY ADDRESS IS A
HIGH SCHOOL. THEY'VE HAD SUCH A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON ALL OF THE
STUDENTS THAT HE ENCOUNTERED
AND WAS A BLESSING TO MY
DISTRICT. DAVE'S LEGACY OF THIS
IS A HIGH SCHOOL WILL FOREVER
LIVE. ON AS THIS IS A UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. UNANIMOUSLY
VOTED TO RENAME THE ISSUES ARE
HIGH SCHOOL. THEATER AT THE
DAVID H. LEWIS THEATER OF THE
PERFORMING ARTS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MR DAVID
H. LEWIS. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESERT PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
WE'LL DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MEMBERS MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING THIRTY MINUTES FROM NOW
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. THAT'S
THIRTY MINUTES FROM NOW ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE TEN THIRTY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO ELECTIONS
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. BANKING
COMMITTEE TWO PM IN THIS
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER. HOUSING
COMMITTEE TWO PM IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH TWO AND THE PURSE
COMMITTEE TWO PM IN ROOM. FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN. SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY APRIL
THIRTIETH NO FLOOR SESSION A
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY MAY THE
THIRD FLOOR SESSION. IS AT ONE
PM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SINGER YOU
KNOW FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MISTER MCCARTY MOVES
AND MR TANG SECONDS. THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MAY THE THIRD AT ONE PM
WE ARE ADJOURNED.
GALLEY VOTE
CHANGE AB TWO SIX THREE I TO
NOT VOTING. THE CHANGES SUMMER
DALLY ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIXTY
THREE I TO NOT VOTING. VOTE
CHANGED TEN AB EIGHT OH FOUR
FROM HEART TO KNOW. BUT CHANGES
ON RETAINING SOME LEVEL IT'LL
FOR I TO KNOW.